[Music]
was reported this week that disgraced
fashion designer John Galliano who was
fired last year by Christian Dior for
making anti-semitic remarks was just
stripped of the Legion of Honour award
that has been given to him by the French
government now at least oh man if you
forgot here's a photo of John Galliano
and here's another photo of John
Galliano and one more photo of John
Galliano well we wanted to talk to
Galliano about his latest humiliation
but he won't answer our calls we were
however able to arrange an interview
with John Galliano's brother Joe
Galliano please welcome live via
satellite this from Paris John Galliano
hi there Joe
Bonjour cannon yes so Joe tell us it's
been a tough year for your brother how
does he feel about being stripped of his
Legion of Honor Award how does he feel
about it he's devastated
yeah and that award he should keep it
river what you see apparently the French
government no longer thinks that your
brother deserves this award
the French people should all be ashamed
of themselves well I mean come on Joe
isn't it your brother who should really
be ashamed of himself how dare you my
brother's a misunderstood angel who
deserves your compassion a misunderstood
angel most people just think he's a jerk
I said most people Oh
there's people can all go to hell come
on Joe I said Joe yeah absolutely well
alright then Joe thanks for talking to
us
it was nice discussing this with you
it's nice discussing
[Applause]
everybody all right
he was in Paris alright